[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando cheguei na internet era tudo mato
parecia que dava pra saber tudo o que
estava acontecendo quem eram as pessoas
que faltavam conversas quais eram os
sites e blogs que a gente devia ler
quais eram os mesmos que a gente deveria
compartilhar a internet parecia uma
grande janela para o mundo na internet
eu conheci amigos amores eu entendi
sobre a autonomia criativa sobre ter uma
sociedade há quase dez anos eu conhecia
luiza minha sócia pela internet
e nós fizemos dessa paixão por essa
ferramenta um negócio que hoje impacta a
vida de milhares de pessoas
de uns tempos pra cá eu fui percebendo
que essa internet que tanto tinha me
dado ela também estava negociando eu
lembro de um episódio em que eu resolvi
fazer um texto especial de conteúdo
sobre o tema auto cuidado pro meu blog
como jornalista que sou eu mergulhei
profundamente no tema eu li livros que é
referência entre eles têm muita gente e
postei depois que eu postei eu fiz o que
todos nós que usamos redes sociais faz
depois de postar
fui ver quantos haitis eu tinha e eu
tinha um pouco aquilo me deixou mal me
deixou angustiado e eu comecei a pensar
será que ninguém quer ler questão será
que ninguém quer ler o meu texto não
será que eu deveria ter falado de alguma
outra forma será que eu fui bom o
suficiente e aquilo ali ficou em loop na
minha cabeça que é experimentou um pouco
essas sensações a usar as redes sociais
pois tá
gostei de ver pois está esperando
ansiosamente pelos lights deixar de
postar porque tem medo do julgamento que
ainda se comparou com as vidas perfeitas
no instagram e pensou eu não tenho corpo
que eu queria ter
eu não tenho trabalho que eu queria ter
eu não viajo tanto quanto essas pessoas
eu gosto de falar de mim pergunta de
vocês
porque eu enxergo hoje a internet como
uma questão de saúde uma questão de
saúde pública ea gente ainda não pensa
tanto sobre isso
apesar de tudo existem dados que mostram
que 50% dos brasileiros não conseguem
ficar um dia longe do celular
nós somos um dos países que mais passa o
tempo online tem estudos que falam em 9
horas por dia têm outros que falam em 5
existem vários protocolos de saúde que
recomendam que uma criança por exemplo
não têm acesso a nenhuma tela até
completar um ano e meio de idade
várias pessoas que criam tecnologia
vários desses engenheiros do vale do
silício colocam seus filhos em escolas
onde tecnologia não é protagonista eles
adiam ao máximo o tempo que uma criança
vai começar a mexer no ipad por exemplo
isso sem falar em questões como
ansiedade transtorno de imagem de
pressão tudo isso potencializado por
essa por esse excesso de internet que a
gente tem hoje eu vejo essa internet
ainda como o mato como como eu cheguei
mas às vezes ela parece uma selva onde
você entra não sabe direito o que vai
acontecer às vezes você se surpreende
por uma beleza em outras você fica
perdido você sai dali mas machucado
isso tem muito a ver porque a gente vive
no momento a gente vive na era da
economia da atenção é muito vivemos num
sistema capitalista e pagamos por
basicamente tudo que a gente consome
não é curioso que as ferramentas e as
redes que a gente mais usa sejam grátis
é uma coisa a se pensar porque como é
que essas ferramentas grande engenheiro
quanto mais tempo a gente fica nelas
mais dados a gente dá e esses dados por
mais que as empresas de tecnologia fala
em que achei que eles não repassam para
terceiros
vários comitês que regulam a internet
entendem que sim esses dados são
vendidos para terceiros é por isso que
às vezes a gente fala uma coisa no
celular e de repente aparece um anúncio
então quanto às redes e beneficiam
quanto mais tempo a gente fica online
quanto mais a gente mostra desse conta a
judith mas compartilha ea gente ainda
não sabe os impactos disso a gente já
sente no dia a dia que as nossas emoções
são às vezes numa gangorra na montanha
russa e se pergunta
então eu venho aqui ela faz uma coisa na
internet ela veio aqui pra falar mal da
internet e da tecnologia jeito nenhum
como eu falei no começo eu sou
apaixonada pela internet sendo que eu
acho que chegou o momento da gente
colocar essa questão em jogo tem um
autor que eu gosto muito que ele fala
que a internet funciona como a grande
máquina de caça-níquel que a lógica é
como se a gente estivesse num casino
mesmo a gente posta uma foto e logo a
gente volta pra ver se a gente esteve lá
e às vezes há nenhum como tive pouco no
especial às vezes são é uma enxurrada e
aquilo ali libera dopamina no seu corpo
não é à toa que a gente passa o dia
inteiro com essa e celular no bolso até
peguei aqui mas não era ele é ea gente
precisa entender que a tecnologia por si
só internet por si só
nenhuma das duas é ruim agora o uso que
a gente faz dela a gente precisa pensar
sobre o que eu acredito que a gente
ainda está vivendo no jardim de infância
da internet a gente está muito
entusiasmado a gente não larga esse
brinquedo ele é a primeira coisa que a
gente olha geralmente quando acorda ele
é a última coisa que a gente olha quando
vai dormir e quais são as implicações
disso que a gente está deixando tanto da
gente aí e sempre que a gente fala de
futuro nem vem muito uma idéia desse
futuro distópico black mil em que os
robôs vão substituir nosso trabalho e
que nossas casas inteligentes vão
responder a um comando de voz e nunca
vai faltar num papel higiênico assim tá
tudo resolvido esse futuro eu acho que
ele até meio presente já tem muita gente
pensando nele mas eu gosto de pensar no
futuro mais humano porque queria
tecnologias que a gente usa são seres
humanas ea gente precisa entender qual é
a ética por trás qual é o modelo de
negócio que a gente quer para isso a
internet e tem uma parte que me conecta
muito com essa internet janela para o
mundo quando eu vejo por exemplo um
adolescente ativista climática
conseguiram impactar milhares de pessoas
com a sua causa e sendo indicada até o
prêmio nobel
quando eu vejo um ativista escritora e
filósofa como a diesel ribeiro
conseguiram impactar milhares de pessoas
falando de temas como lugar de fala
racismo branquitude negritude eu vejo
que a internet deu certo
todo dia uma mulher e se descobre
feminista por quê
ela viu um post de uma amiga e ela
percebeu que várias coisas que ela já
intuía o que ela sentia que ela vivia na
vida tinha nome
isso é muito poderoso todo dia uma
pessoa lgbt sai do armário e entenda a
importância de fazer disse isso na
internet também porque o amor
resistência nas nossas comunidades eu
vejo a potência que acontece quando as
pessoas se juntam para aprender sobre o
tema
a gente fala de inúmeros falamos de
alimentação natural de toque digital
falamos de envelhecimento de
auto-cuidado isso em uma comunidade de
pessoas que estão dispostas a usar
melhor esse tempo que elas façam no
celular para criar uma conexão mais
verdadeira para aprender sobre o assunto
então o que eu vim falar aqui hoje é que
a gente precisa se conectar novamente
com essa palavra conexão e criar uma
nova internet
essa que a gente vive usa 24 horas por
dia sete dias por semana a gente já tem
inúmeros exemplos que ela não tá dando
certo
no entanto a gente só passa esse tempo
inteiro no celular porque a gente tem um
desejo profundo de conexão
não é à toa que a gente tem um monte de
grupo notícias ap não é à toa que a
gente tem perfis em redes sociais
a gente quer se conectar um dos estudos
de raiva de mim que analisou a vida
adulta das pessoas revelou que o que faz
a diferença na felicidade das pessoas é
o poder de conexão não são bens
materiais não são viáveis não é acumular
dinheiro às vezes não é nem do filho mas
é se conectar de forma profunda e
verdadeira com as pessoas
é por isso que eu acredito que chegou a
hora da gente criar a internet que a
gente quer que exista essa internet é um
lugar plural e diverso é um lugar onde
vozes que antes não eram ouvidas é co
é um lugar onde a gente tem conversas
não pra vencer uma discussão e para
provar que está certo mas é um lugar em
que a gente quer entender o outro a
gente quer ouvir em um lugar de empatia
e compaixão na internet que a gente quer
a informação é ouro e fake news é
praticamente coisa do passado
imagina que sonha chegar nesse lugar e
essa conexão ela acontece em vários
pilares pra você se conectar
verdadeiramente enxergo três
possibilidades você se conectar com você
mesmo porque quando você se conecta com
você mesmo você olha para dentro e
começa a trilhar um caminho de
autoconhecimento e não tem mais volta
você não consegue ver mais as coisas
quando você se conecta com o outro
novamente
você chega nesse lugar de empatia você
não precisa dar certo existem diversas
visões de mundo ea gente precisa acolher
o diferente também
e quando você se conecta com o mundo
você entender as causas que importam
você encontra sua turma
você entende a potência que é quando a
gente resolve fazer uma mudança
juntos é por isso que eu acredito que a
conexão é capaz de nos salvar
ela já nos salvou de números absurdos
que a gente viveu ao longo dos anos e
ela vai continuar nos salvando e é por
isso que eu tenho um convite pra vocês
hoje
da próxima vez que vocês forem pegar o
celular que eu sei que daqui a pouco eu
queria que vocês olhar sem ele como essa
janela de possibilidades como essa
janela para o mundo
eu queria que a gente combinar se aqui
que a gente vai se proteger que a gente
vai dar unfollow que a gente vai parar
de seguir aquilo que não acrescenta que
a gente vai cuidar das nossas emoções e
que a gente vai principalmente ampliar
nossa visão de mundo
não vamos ser só coadjuvante da internet
não vamos só ficar fazendo carinho na
tela como falam amigo meu
vamos usar a internet como forma de
expressão vamos colocar nosso potencial
ali vamos experimentar o que é se
expressar e e descobrir que você tem uma
audiência
falando em audiência vamos dar nossa
audiência para aquilo que a gente quer
ver florescer
eu acho que é muito evitável nesse mundo
que a gente vive hoje não compartilhar
as tragédias as notícias ruins todo dia
são várias mas assim como eu falei mas
no começo a nossa atenção no nosso live
o nosso comentário são as nossas moedas
única está investindo porque em vez de
compartilhar uma história
deixa mal você não aproveita e
compartilham que deixa bem que se
conecta com você com o outro e com o
mundo
vamos ser exemplo também as crianças
estão crescendo todos querem sem o tubo
e elas ficam o tempo inteiro usando
internet celular
vamos convidá los para essa conversa e
principalmente vamos entender que existe
momento para estar conectado existe
momento para estar presente
aliás presença um presente vamos lembrar
de respirar quando uma coisa não estiver
legal e vamos lembrar de não usar o
celular o tempo inteiro e vamos
principalmente ser a mudança que a gente
quer ver no mundo
essa ferramenta é maravilhosa e nunca
provavelmente a gente estará menos
conectado do que a gente está hoje
então o meu convite é para que a gente
se conecte de verdade se conecta com a
nossa verdade encontra em nossa turma
encontra em nossas comunidades e que a
gente possa ser agente de transformação
e que a gente possa criar um mundo que a
gente quer que exista
vamos juntos obrigada
[Aplausos]